good afternoon my name is Jessica
Flannery and I'm a first year doctor of
public health student at Harvard th Chan
School of Public Health it is a
privilege to introduce dr. Atul Gawande
dr. Gawande practices general and
endocrine surgery at Brigham and Women's
Hospital he is a professor in the
Department of Health Policy and
management at the Harvard th Chan School
of Public Health and in the Department
of Surgery at Harvard Medical School dr.
Gawande is also the executive director
of Ariadna labs
a joint center for health systems
innovation and the founder and chairman
of the life box foundation a non-profit
working to reduce surgery deaths
globally dr. Gawande Zaka Demick work
includes extensively published research
on surgery and healthcare since 2007 dr.
Gawande has led the World Health
Organization's safe surgery saves lives
program along with his notable medical
and academic accomplishments dr. Gawande
is best known for his notable writing he
has written four best-selling books and
has been a staff writer for The New
Yorker magazine since 1998 dr. Gawande
recalls that early in his career he
struggled with writing however he has
since earned two National Magazine
Awards and the lowest Thomas Award for
writing and science in 2006 dr. Gawande
received a MacArthur Foundation
fellowship known as a genius grant his
work and writings have made significant
contributions to the field and public
discourse on medical practice ethics and
health care dr. Gawande is most recent
book being mortal medicine and what
matters in the end was published in
October of 2014 and quickly rose to the
number one New York Times bestseller and
remains among the top 10 best-selling
non-fiction books the extensively
researched book is making phenomenal
contributions to the national
conversation on end-of-life care in
February of 2015
PBS Frontline turned the book into a
widely acclaimed documentary
dr. Gawande Spath is as full and diverse
as his current career he earned his
medical degree from Harvard Medical
School in 1995 after a brief absence to
work as a health care adviser to Bill
Clinton he then earned a Master of
Public Health degree from Harvard School
of Public Health in 1999 before I turn
the session over to our moderator today
dr. Lucien leap professor of Health
Policy please join me in welcoming dr.
Atul Gawande to the voices in leadership
series at the Harvard th Chan School of
Public Health well I want to add my
welcome to it's just a delight to have
you here I've watched your career for a
long time and it's inspired so many
people so it's great to have an
opportunity to put you on the spot any
less that what really makes you tick and
we that may be a place to start you've
had an interesting trajectory you
graduated Stanford you were a Rhodes
Scholar at Oxford graduate from Harvard
Medical School but I noticed that in
that sequence it took you a long time to
graduate from Harvard Medical School
there were about six or seven years in
there so you were doing something else
you want to tell us what you were doing
and why well so first of all I should
confess that Lucien has been a mentor
mentor of mine from the moment I came to
the school Public Health so it's fun to
get to talk with you as a fellow surgeon
pediatric surgeon who had gone into
public health so it's and I think that
pathway is as convoluted as if in your
life as it has been in mind I was in
medical school after taking five years
to even decide I was going to get there
I had taken a pathway that where I did
two years in politics and philosophy at
Oxford I'd hoped that I might become a
philosopher and do a PhD in philosophy
but I found I couldn't really understand
the questions the Philosopher's were
asking let alone offer anything in the
way of original answers and so I stuck
with the masters
and then and then I worked in politics
for a while so I worked on Al Gore's
presidential campaign back in 1988
short-lived campaign people may not
remember but it was his admission of
having smoked pot at here at Harvard
that contributed to his having to walk
away from that campaign at the time the
world changed by 1992 and I'd started
medical school when I was working in
politics I'd worked on a health plan
with a southern Democrat named Jim
Cooper representing Tennessee I had
worked for him for about a year and a
half and so when I started medical
school the plan was that you know this
is what I'm going to stick with but
health reform became an issue in the 92
election enough that when Bill Clinton
ran his head of policy asked if I would
join the team as their health policy
advisor and social policy advisor so you
know I think I was probably number 32 on
the list of people they asked by the
time at that point I was 26 years old
but the job required you to move to
Little Rock Arkansas this was during the
primaries Clinton was not even in the
top two at that time seven Democrats
running they were called the Seven
Dwarves because bush senior had 70
percent favorability ratings so you know
by that I was asked to join and for me
it was an amazing opportunity and I
believed in Bill Clinton I'd met him
during the time when he was governor
when we were crafting a health plan that
Southern Democrats could sign on to and
so I took a leave of absence from
medical school it ended up being almost
two years because lo and behold we won
the primary I had proposed to my now
wife at that time and she she had moved
up to Boston I said well they got this
job offer don't worry we'll lose before
we got out of the primary and then we
won the primary and go into the general
election I said to her well we're
supposed to get married two weeks after
the election don't worry about working
lose it'll work out fine and then just
one thing led to another until finally
in ended up working in the White House
and in the Department of Health and
Human Services and then I made the
decision after health reform went down
the the head of the welfare reform
effort was David Ellwood who's now the
Dean of the Kennedy School of Government
and he had asked if I would join the
team to work on welfare reform and I
decided I need needed to forge my own
set of skills it was a hard decision the
group of people I was with you know
there was a bunch of us who were young
people working on policy and and you
know I didn't love the ups and downs of
the sharp political elbows people you
agree with who would muscle you out of
meetings you know playing that that game
and I didn't know how I felt about
working exclusively my career for
politicians so I decided to go back and
and complete medical school I'd lost
some ground and had to make it up but
that's what I came back to do thank you
for coming back I think I first met you
when you were in the middle of your
surgical residency hmm you were spending
some time over here working on the
medical practice that he follow up but
that was the first time I recognized
that you had some interest in safety but
how did you get an interest in patient
safety how did that fit in with this it
was you you know I didn't have a
particular interest in focus on medical
error but I was interested in
identifying problems that we could solve
and I had started a set of studies that
was in with another mentor Troy Brennan
who was here at the School of Public
Health at the time he was a lawyer doing
medical research on malpractice with you
and the follow-up study that he's
describing was one where we had data
from Utah and Colorado
across hospitals 15,000 patients and
hospitals across the state and I was in
charge of looking at the surgical data
and what I was interested in is how much
of the people who died was because they
had complications of care where we just
didn't know the answers and the problem
is ignorance and we need to overcome
that with more scientific research
around in the bench lab and how much was
because then they just didn't execute
that there was knowledge that existed
but people died from complications that
could have been prevented
we found that two-thirds of the surgical
deaths were from really error and that
they accounted for also two-thirds of
the deaths and hospitals in the state so
that's when I came started tagging along
with you and you were running a program
at the Kennedy School of Government
there were bringing civic leaders
together not just medical leaders but
people from politics and a wide variety
of fields saying what do we do about
this problem that you recognized years
before and you got me interested I'll
take full credit well we we want to talk
about yours I do I want to point out
though yes you brought me along as a
brand-new student at the School of
Public Health everybody else in the room
were people with an enormous amount of
experience and just getting to be in
there that's what made it possible yeah
well it was it was certainly a very good
investment to say the least
we want to talk about your leadership in
all three areas that you've excelled in
in writing in research and in surgery
and and I think writing is the logical
place to start because that's where most
people are familiar with your work and I
must say I'll never forget the first
piece of yours in The New Yorker that I
read I don't think was your first piece
but it was called the learning curve and
you described the experience you had in
learning how to insert a central line
this is putting a big needle in
somebody's neck and trying to find the
vein and I was reading this
your description of it of how
frustrating it was and your your you
were frightening you or you weren't sure
what was going to happen next and I was
reading this and saying yes yes that's
just the way it is and I realized I was
sweating and I said this is somebody who
really knows how to write and so let's
ask you that question
this was you started running from New
York or just about the same time you
were over here looking at patient safety
are they related and more importantly
how did you get started writing to New
Yorker and how did you learn to write so
well I did not have a plan it was not
clearly related at all I have always had
a a variety of interests I never thought
writing would be one of them
I had my worst grades and in college
were in writing and well there's a take
home and and I think I didn't have
anything to write about is the most
important thing I had nothing to say in
surgical residency forged by fire then
getting a chance to pull back and think
about it in a public health atmosphere
where you're thinking about you know how
do we solve problems for entire
populations it writing was the way that
I could stay connected as a surgery
resident stay connected to public policy
issues without having to be full-time
you know like being in politics as a
full-time sport you have to be there day
and day out you know my wife thought
that surgical residency was a was better
for her life than being in politics we
got two days off in the entire year in
an entire year working in that world and
so the bottom line for me was that
writing started out as just an
experiment a friend of mine had started
an Internet magazine this was 1996 when
it was the netscape browser if any of
you remember that so you know you'd
literally get if you're lucky hundreds
of hits
and for me where as a terrible writer
that was beautiful I can almost do it in
obscurity but I was working with a
friend who had been in journalism a long
time and he and the people he gathered
were fantastic editors and so I wrote a
series of what you've now called blogs
we called him a column then but I had
editing so it was like getting to do 30
gallbladders in a row with a surgeon
standing across the table from you I did
30 columns in a row with really great
editors telling me this is what you're
doing well this is what you're not doing
well and boy that argument is really
pretty weak and let's see if you can
make it better
I was forced to revise I never revised
anything you know I had to learn how to
really revise and so when it was more
happenstance than anything it started as
really being about public policy issues
my first article one of my first
articles was about Governor george w
bush and the policy he had signed into
law in texas allowing criminals to be
freed if they agreed to castration if
they had been rapists or convicted of
child molestation like now what do we
think of that policy but it morphed into
talking about my own experiences in
recognize dealing with errors
understanding how you deal with
imperfection and medicine and thinking
about some of these other kinds of
issues and so you know it was the
influence of being in this mix of the
different things I was working on on the
research side living a life of trying to
learn how to be a surgeon and thinking
about public policy that kind of forged
a series of articles in The New Yorker
turned out that as the magazine grew it
was slate magazine slate went from a few
hundred hits to by the time I finished
in two years was three hundred thousand
hits per article and among those that
was reading it was a New York New Yorker
editor who offered the chance to try
writing for them and I started with
small articles in it and it grew over
time you once said you revise your first
New Yorker article a number of time 22
times I thought it would you know I
thought it'd be a couple
months of work it was nine months of
work going back and back and back and
you know but I had to admit it kept
getting better so it was painful but the
editor would keep throwing me another
task and it would keep making the
article better it's better so we went
that was I think that key difference was
I learned I'm an okay writer with a
first draft but I learned how to revise
to get it to the point that I could be a
really a much stronger more vivid writer
and make it sound like conversation and
that takes a lot of cutting cutting
cutting rewriting rewriting rewriting it
was James Michener's somebody said
you're a great writer he says no I'm a
great rewriter but you're in the same
Club trying to learn to do that yes now
the other two big areas that you've
contributed so much in our research and
surgery and they came together when the
World Health Organization asks you to
run a safe safe for surgery project I
remember you came in to me and said what
do you think about this and I said well
WH o is not the easiest place to work
with on the other hand big big
possibility for making an impact and you
decide to do it and and I think would be
very interesting for people to
understand not only what led you to make
that decision but more importantly in
terms of the leadership aspect how you
were able to corral a group of surgeons
of all people from around the world and
get them to focus how you came to a
conclusion about what to do and and what
were the challenges and the leadership
challenges in carrying that thing off
yeah and for me it was an evolving sense
of what was going to be the way that I'd
learned to lead I think a lot of my
thinking coming out of government and
politics and then my initial writing was
that where change occurs was really
around laws and policy and regulations
and trying to move those needles but
many of the problems I felt like we saw
in making equitable high quality health
care that could reach a large number of
people was that there are many problems
that simply hadn't been
solved or accepted or agreed upon even
by the profession and so the World
Health Organization asked me to take on
this project which was to see if we
could reduce deaths and surgery globally
and I was still in the back of my mind
thinking that this might be about
policies or things like that we launched
into the project it was not funded very
well it was a small amount of money to
convene a lot of leaders in and around
surgery and try to make a kind of set of
guidelines about care but what was clear
with the team that I assembled as we all
wanted to actually see whatever we did
make a difference so we're going to go
to all this work and if it doesn't if it
just sits on a shelf somewhere as a book
of guidelines that's that doesn't get
anywhere and the more we dug into it
more we felt and that the problems were
not ones a policy but how to reduce
deaths and surgery how to make a
feasible pathway that anybody anywhere
doing surgery could successfully lower
deaths and that was what we decided to
tackle there were about 10 major things
that you could do to reduce infections
in surgery and make sure that you had
problems with bleeding brought under
control and good communications and all
these basic things but it was really
meeting people who helped us understand
you know what you really got to think
about how you make these things become a
reality we zeroed in on after we brought
in a team from Boeing a leader who was a
leader of engineering for Boeing that we
recognized you could just make a
checklist for surgery and then it was
selling it from Boeing but very much
yeah that we brought in a safety
engineer who helped us understand how
they work with professionals and for
Boeing it wasn't you know as much
regulations regulations create a
framework that say they're expected to
deliver on safety but then they are that
the government does not prescribe what's
in a checklist they make the checklist
that makes it possible for very
professional people you know pilots who
are well trained to achieve much better
results than they otherwise would and so
that became a project
that you know we kept following that
path and as long as we were staying
focused on what produces results what
saves lives you could bring the rest of
the world along there were definitely
you know difficult moments where you
definitely where you had people in the
profession surgeons leaders in the field
saying this is a waste of time it's more
paperwork it's a bad idea but we
committed to testing it at small scale
expanding it to an eighth city trial
demonstrating whether it works or does
not work but once we began showing and
we found a 47% reduction in death across
eight cities so once you had done that
then it really was okay how do we not
commit to following through on
delivering it to ever larger scale well
it's clearly been one of the most
impactful advances in patient safety and
the whole history of the movement but I
SPECT you're your problems then just
began when people started implementing
and I just wonder you're you've been
around long enough to know that just
putting a good idea out doesn't make it
happen and so I suspect you were
prepared for some pushback and from some
criticisms from your colleagues maybe
hoping that wouldn't happen but that so
what happened when it when your article
came out and people began talking about
actually putting it in place how did
those experiences go huh but in your own
Hospital for example well so it was um
you know great learning experience on
the one hand there were early adopters
and there were places just you know you
had leaders who grabbed it and ran with
it and put it in their hospitals and
began publishing that they were getting
replicating those results 25% 50%
reductions in complications and deaths
you had some countries like England that
the day after it came out they mandated
that it be implemented in the hospitals
across the country you had a country
like the US where it was still a great
deal of uncertainty I don't know that
we really need this and even in my own
Hospital puzzling over like how we need
to adopt this in our hospital but how do
you even convince your colleagues to
make that happen I mean it took six
months to just find a meeting where the
surgeons anesthesiologists and nurses
all sit down together and make plans
around care and that was reflective of
where we were we weren't even organizing
ourselves as teams and we didn't have a
place to make it happen
I found the finance meeting that we
could hijack because that was the one
place you could get them together was in
the finance meeting and you know the the
Boston often is a place that if it
didn't invent it is a late adopter we're
necessarily we may be slower to jump on
board and so it began really moving in
many places and then in Boston that
began catching on as people kept
demonstrating and replicating the
results we also saw plenty of examples
where the results not come through in
Canada just a couple years ago they
published results when Canada mandated
that the checklist be used all the
hospitals signed off we're absolutely
weird we're using the checklist it's the
law and we're abiding by the law they
measured three months after they had
implemented and found no reduction in
deaths and our you know as we peered in
more closely it's clear there wasn't a
real implementation support or rollout
and we had to learn what that means
so in Scotland they rolled it out they
mandated it but they sent they bought
teams together to walk through every few
months what are you doing to roll this
out and they said coaches do site visits
to say what are the problems you're
running into and let's help you solve
them they found it took them three years
to create countrywide cultural change to
create the adoption but by that point
they had lowered their death rates 25
percent enough that they documented
9,000 live saved so it's shown us a
great deal about knowing what to do is
not the same as knowing how to do it so
the first question what do you do to
lower surgical deaths now we knew a how
use a checklist much as they do in
aviation
how do you get people to use a checklist
was another puzzle and over the years
what we found is it's a combination of
really needing you can't just pay them
or create a regulation that says you
have to do it you have to recognize it's
a culture change and walk people hand in
hand through a hospital process a team
process where they can get everybody on
board with making a very complex change
even though it seems like a simple two
minute checklist shouldn't be so
complicated so it's really about culture
change not not just ticking off the
boxes
yeah and leadership so you know surgeons
are used to the idea that no one tells
us what to do about the way we do our
operations got the new ship captain ship
and I make the rules the idea that there
would be a standardized way for any
component of the way that we do things
the way we communicate the way we plan
the way we work together as a team
that's what the checklist was really
doing was saying we're going to have a
scripted way that we discuss what the
goals of the operation are how we were
going to get it done and that was the
culture change to go from Cowboys to pit
crews where we would agree we would
really be a pit crew for the patient and
that I'm finding is true across many
problems in public health luckily as
we've spread our work into trying to
figure out how do you make change for
childbirth or how do you make change for
people's end-of-life care at the
beginning of life and end-of-life has
been other projects we've gotten
involved in it's been again this idea
that there are known ways that you can
be more effective and can we make it
easy for people to adopt those known
ways effectively and if we show that it
works then you kind of got to do it
and that's and that's a hard place to
come to that's a basic lesson for all
the things we're trying to do in patient
safety one area I want to ask you about
is something I think many people in the
audience may not be familiar with and
that is what I think is one of your most
important leadership contribution which
was the founding of the Ariadne labs
there any labs I will read from the
mission statement so I get incorrect and
then ask you what's this all about our
mission is to create scalable
health care solutions that produce
better care at the most critical moments
in people's lives everywhere and then
they go on to stay and I think this is
particularly fascinating part it is not
enough to research a problem and launch
a program at Ariadne labs we go further
we ensure that our programs can be
effectively adapted and successfully
implemented across thousands of
healthcare facilities and diverse
cultures Wow tell us how that came about
and tell us the pitfalls and trying to
do such an ambitious project I think it
came out of the World Health
Organization experience that you could
identify ways the system fails you could
identify approaches that simplified it
through research and discovery and
innovation but if all we did was publish
an article in 2009 in the New England
Journal saying we ran a nice trial and
and please everybody adopt this not very
much what have happened and we really
had to embark on learning the science of
how do you evaluate of how you bring
something to scale and so that is meant
now moving from saying okay can we make
this work in a very controlled pretty
limited 8 Hospital trial in eight cities
just saying you know we created a
partnership a year or two after that in
the state of South Carolina with all of
the hospitals in the state trying to
measure what their death rates were and
how to bring this capability across the
hospital across the state and why some
places we're succeeding in other places
weren't we had another partnership with
the Washington State Hospital
Association another one with the country
of New Zealand and it was very
interesting in Washington State they
worked with their insurers and they paid
doctors and hospitals to adopt in New
Zealand they regulated it and made it a
mandate in regulation in law South
Carolina being a red state did not want
to make it a mandate in law being a
state that wasn't as wealthy as
Washington State they didn't want to pay
for it so we used a social networking
approach where we tried sending a team
of people just four people around the
state to krei
partnerships in every hospital with
surgeons anesthesiologists and nurses
willing to work together to bring it
into their hospitals and the striking
thing was that simply paying doctors are
regulating wasn't nearly as effective as
going forward with the social networking
approach and those kinds of discoveries
led us to want to launch a lab because
we could bring those capabilities not to
just a sequence of a serial set of
projects but we could launch ones in
parallel fields in surgery yes where
we've expanded the range of things we're
doing in the field but then in
childbirth how how we can make
improvements at the beginning of life
and how you could make improvements at
the end of life in a palliative care
program and there you were you know we
were positing the idea that with
attracting people across the whole city
doing work to make changes to improve
health systems and try to bring them to
scale we would find people who had
common cause and wanting to do it so we
launched projects but we also are
building the community you know
community now that has a couple hundred
researchers and people from across the
city 45 associate faculty members who
are building work in these areas and now
creating projects well beyond anything
that I'm even necessarily involved with
you know people solving everything from
how do we reduce these section rates in
the country to how do we bring
behavioral mental health care that
really doesn't get to 75 percent of the
population with any kind of appropriate
depth how do we get that scaling up and
working can technology make a difference
those kinds of things it's really
impressive and I'm sure it's the wave of
the future I think our time for for you
and me is up it's time to have questions
from the audience and raise your hand
and we'll have you ask a tool anything
you want yes I have bits and chains
thank you for your remarks my question
is do you feel that your theory can be
adaptable to doctor patient healthcare
in terms of one tool or the mattek-sands
through
country watch mine um so your question
is do our ideas have application to
people really outside the hospital in
the ambulatory setting where it's more
one-to-one in clinics rather than having
a team like in an operating room or in a
child delivery well we're learning that
in our child in our end of life work the
gap that we're seeing in care for people
facing serious illness not even
necessarily at the end of life is that
as care escalates but produces but but
comes up against the limits of people's
lives people often end up with care
that's completely on the line with their
actual goals and wishes but the failure
to make their wishes known before they
got to the hospital in crisis before
they were ending up in surgery before
they were in an emergency room in
delirious with pain is that you had to
make a system that could work upstream
in the doctor's office we design and
approach which is now deploying at a
small scale in the Dana Farber Cancer
Institute and in the primary care
practices affiliated with the Brigham
the hospital I practice at where it is
simply saying that when the doctor and
the patient sit down they would ask a
few key questions that palliative care
experts have demonstrated to be really
powerful but we don't do those kinds of
questions or things like asking people
what's your understanding of where you
are with your health or your illness at
this time do you want to have more
information about where things might be
going in the future with your disease
what are your fears for the future what
are your goals and priorities if time
were short or your health worsened what
are you willing to sacrifice what are
you not willing to sacrifice so it's we
call it the seven questions approach
bringing those questions into the clinic
and operationalizing them meant creating
a system that tried to make it easy for
a doctor to know which of their patients
are the highest risk of dying in the
next year
identifying for those patients for them
on their clinic schedule and then giving
them reminders you know it's been two
visits you haven't had this conversation
and they're in danger of heading into a
crisis could you do that and we found
were able to make it work so far in this
still small scale pilot still it's
thousands of patients I mean it's not
that small scale we have 60% of the
primary care patients in medic on
Medicare in in the n1 and 80% of the
cancer patients and the other you know
to reminders we're getting 90% of the
patients having a conversation that up
till now less than 30% we're having the
conversation we're trying to see what
the impact is and then figure out how to
bring it to more places so I think we're
learning how to bring it out of the
hospital to smaller teams with less
resources but still really important
roles and places and care hi I'm Jessica
Lange so police officers are like
surgeons and pilots in that they have to
make split-second decisions under
stressful circumstances and errors have
deadly consequences I'm wondering if you
could envision the safety checklist
approach being used to train police
officers to reduce wrongful shootings so
this is so cool
edy Davis the chief of police in what he
just stepped down from being chief of
police he was chief police through the
Marathon bombing he had come to us
around creating a homicide checklist so
I don't know yet about how you might
apply it in wrongful shootings but he
applied into homicide investigations and
found incredible value Boston had one of
the lowest clearance rates for homicide
investigations in the country and they
followed and mirrored the approach we
followed with surgery they gathered a
lot of information from how other police
departments did it tried to figure out
what those police departments thought
were their best practices and then they
created a checklist for homicide
investigators and he said there were
things on there like you know in many
cities in Boston it's up to the crime
scene up to the homicide investigator
whether they bring a crime scene
investigators see
sigh to gather evidence in a really
structured way or whether they do it
themselves it's up to their discretion
in other cities they always have a CSI
on scene and they found that one of the
reasons why in Boston they had failures
was that they didn't gather the evidence
appropriately and now you lost your
evidence and it made it hard to reach a
conviction or a clearance on what
actually happened so that's just one of
several steps that they identified and
they were able to make it go and then
they were able to walk through the hard
process how do you convince surgeons
well how do you convince homicide
investigators to not do things their own
way whatever way and they just mirrored
the way it went and now there's a
National Institute of Justice study a
randomized trial evaluating whether this
is what all cities should do because
it's worked phenomenally well in Boston
so I think that you know people have
brought that approach to successfully
reducing the domestic abuse deaths with
what police should do and with domestic
violence victims and I think in wrongful
shooting that taking these approaches
that these are probably fundamentally
systems failures rather than failures of
character of policemen and that taking
it seriously as a research and
innovation need as a systems need I'm
pretty sure would work as well
hi my name is IRA lor cobby I'm a
geriatrician and I want to thank you so
much for your book being mortal and just
bringing culture change to the general
public my question for you is actually
what can we do for nursing homes from a
policy level they sort of you know keep
getting left out with the SGR repeal now
nursing homes still are left out of
Medicare's conversation just wondering
what your thoughts are on that yeah so
that surprised to me as I was writing
being mortal my most recent book I
thought it was going to be a bad end of
life but what it was really about
two-thirds of the book ended up being
about Aging and care of elder care
especially housing care and I realized
that there comes a moment in your life
when either because of illness or
frailty or other conditions you you need
help of others you need to depend on
them and if you if they're not clear
about what your goals are it's a problem
the assumption in the medical world is
your number one goal is to survive and
be and and and be healthy but in fact
most people in their lives demonstrate
ways in which you know go to your
refrigerator and you're making choices
all the time about sacrifices that you
make around what might be ideal for your
health you go into nursing homes and
you'll have a medically prescribed very
healthy diet and no say over what you
get to eat and in many circumstances you
know I'd meet an 85 year old Alzheimer's
patient who's hoarding cookies hiding
them in their room because they're under
medically ordered diets that say you can
only pureed foods and they were
miserable and no one was asking what
matters in your life and sometimes they
blamed policy the nursing home
administrators they'd say well the
policies and the way we're measured is
are we keeping people safe so you get
measured around the number of Falls the
result is that you tell people you know
you should stay in a wheelchair
shouldn't even try to walk because then
you fall but people want to try
for those moments of Independence and so
on so one of the things that I came
across was that you know I think there
are some policy directions which involve
creating measures that really evaluate
whether people are in are receiving care
where people know what their priorities
and and what their priorities are
besides just being safe and that they
feel that those priorities are respected
and if there's conflict there are ways
already within the system to allow
people to you know have agreements that
that you know what I can eat what I want
even if it's not safe and and that
everybody can come to agreements around
those kinds of things and I think making
sure that that's clear and easy and can
be done is really important the further
question about how to have funding and
experiments in the ways we deliver care
to get it closer to the home in an
environments where people feel really in
there that they're in control that
they're in charge I think is is really
important it's sort of still unclear to
me you know what are the three or five
most important policies that would help
people be successful in protecting their
autonomy as well as their safety
is still a little bit unclear I think
we're just waking up to the fact that
most places that the elderly end up in
its chosen by their children their adult
children the adult children are focused
as one nursing home administrator said
safety is what we want for those we love
but autonomy is what we want for
ourselves and we they never get asked
what are you doing to ensure this person
gets what matters most in their life and
gets to articulate what matters to them
and make that part of care so I feel
like we're opening the door now to
demand that and then begin having
expectations around the policies that it
should align with that our policies have
focused
on safety and that's important here
you're talking to two safety researchers
but life is bigger than just aiming for
safety and we haven't incorporated that
into our thinking we've medicalized that
whole process and that's been a danger
let me pick up on being mortal because
although it's Jessica indicated
immediately went on the bestseller list
and has been number one for half a least
half of the time and it's still there
and I think we'll be there for another
year I don't think I've seen a book in
recent memory that has had as much
impact as being mortal has had and one
of the most impressive things to me is
how it has changed the conversation and
I've always thought of that as one
definition of leadership that is
changing the conversation on an
important subject and I think that's
exactly what you had in mind but I want
to ask you about one other aspect and
that is you were also giving a clear
message to the physician community we've
got to change the way we practice and
I'm sure you realize that that was going
to be fraught and I'm curious to what
extent you were concerned about that and
whether you've had pushback or problems
with the whole idea of physicians
changing the way they approach the
end-of-life well so my frame and
anything that I'm writing is always to
ask what should I be doing differently
better next week that that you know just
would make me more effective in reaching
the goals and I felt really incompetent
dealing with people who had serious
issues of aging and ability or terminal
illness they didn't teach you that in
medical school yeah and then going
around and discovering that you know we
as a profession weren't doing some basic
things that a few people in very
marginalized fields for the most part in
our world you know palliative care
hospice care nursing home care but they
knew stuff that we weren't valuing and
that basic set of values were often very
simple things like you know recognizing
that people have priorities besides just
living longer asking them what those
priorities are and then incorporating it
into your plan
care that when you didn't do that it
created incredible suffering and that I
could try it and do it in my own
practice in ways that remarkably changed
my own practice and how people felt
about my care along the way that was one
step but the further step I feel like
that was the wake-up call was then my
dad got the brain tumor that took his
life and accompanying him on physicians
office visits he's a surgeon my mother
is a doctor and I would go as well and
we would feel often completely unable to
understand how we can align what they're
talking about with what he cared about
in the time he had remaining and I think
that allowed me to say pretty blunt
things about the ways in which we fail
because I could watch how there were
moments when people did incredible
things for him they were completely and
aligned with what he needed and pushed
him to do things that were the right
things to push him but when they didn't
understand him it led to really pretty
awful care and saying it I didn't I
often when I'm writing I'm not thinking
enough about how people might react but
when I'm revising I start getting
worried and then as my editor saying no
don't don't tell Matt down say you said
it before just say it
and and I do always worry when it goes
out will people receive it in the way
that I'm describing it which is as
someone wondering how I might be getting
better and what that means about how we
all might be better at what we're doing
and and the pushback has not been there
I feel really lucky than people for the
most part with my writing and research
have received it with the intention I
had in mind I'm sometimes saying hard
things even about even for myself to
confront the ways that my own practice
or my own ways of being in the world are
not always the best and and so that that
I worry about it maybe that does make me
it revised extra carefully for not
creating this interpretation and so far
I've lucked out that it hasn't come back
to bite me I got a note just this you
know this kind of note came last week
from a cardiologist who does in Michigan
who does you know interventional
cardiology so you know a gung-ho cowboy
just like any other like a surgeon like
me and and had someone sent in from a
nursing home work where the family was
very unhappy with the opinions of two
previous cardiologists and had just read
the book and just said well let me just
ask them what are what are what what it
asked them nine year old patient what
are your goals what's most important to
you and then ask the family and realize
they weren't in a line and then got them
in line and then concluded that what she
really wanted was that the remaining
time she had was spent with a better
quality of life that she got some better
food in her nursing home and had no
interest in going through the
catheterization and for him that was a
revelation and this was a chief of
Cardiology and the fact that he wrote
that note and sent it along to me it
just made my day and made my like that
was where I felt like we were connecting
we were talking the same language we
actually have the same values we just
you know had been doing it differently
and could you arrive in the same place
you got him to ask the right question
other questions
back
hi my name is Angela nee and I'm a
master student health policy management
program here and you wrote a very
provocative piece about the use of
coach's personal professional coaches to
help top performers to the top of their
game not just in music and athletes but
also for doctors and I wonder have you
seen sort of perceptions around coaches
changed since you wrote that piece and
found ways to integrate the use of
coaches in some of your projects and
ongoing work so there's two different
answers there one is that I've been
disappointed about the about that piece
not creating a wave in quite the same
way I think there's been a ton of
individual interest but people haven't
figured out how to operationalize the
idea so the core concept was I was
contrasting the notion of a kind of the
pedagogical model model we have in most
of healthcare and in many fields law
judges or all kinds of fields teachers
that the expectations you get lots of
training the beginning you get some
experience you get your 10,000 hours and
then you're kind of you go out in the
world and you're expected to improve
yourself for the rest of your career
whereas athletes do not believe that you
know Rafael Nadal Djokovic number one
players in the world have coaches for
their entire career because they don't
believe they can dissect and improve
themselves as well I ended up
experimenting with having a coach a
former professor of mine I'm at
mid-career felt like I wasn't getting
any better I was feeling like I was very
good I felt like I was where I should be
as a surgeon but I experiment with
having them come to the operating room
and just watching me operate and giving
me some feedback and you know afterwards
he had 20 different things that he
pointed out that I could be doing better
and I spent the next year gradually
whittling away at doing it and I found
my complication drop rates dropped even
further and the idea that you need
external eyes and ears and that there
are ways of getting feedback that allow
you to keep climbing as you go through
the middle part of your profession
and beyond that still hasn't quite
caught on in medicine there are places
that are now have really introduced
coaches for people in their first couple
years of practice or for people in the
training phase but the idea that you
need these at later stages you know most
CEOs have coaches they've accepted that
but it hasn't come to these other
professions it's starting to happen
though I just did a you know there's a
one group that's spun out of that
article was that the Massachusetts
judges so there's over 200 judges across
the state created a program they call
judge to judge based on that article
which is awesome and that's where senior
people in the on the bench will go and
observe other coaches other judges as
they handle their juries as they
interact and give them feedback let them
see themselves in ways that they don't
they even use videotape in that program
and it's fascinating so you know you
have people are members of the Supreme
Judicial Council our Supreme Court in
the state who are going through this
program and accepting that kind of
approach so I think we're we're not
quite there now in our program in our
laboratory Ariadne labs we use coaching
very regularly that it's the most
important tool we think for reaching
scale it's often coaching leaders in
places trying to implement difficult
programs whether it's a checklist and
surgery or end-of-life project or in
northern India program that is trying to
reduce deaths and childbirth and we're
teaching nurses to coach nurses doctors
to coach doctors and and and trying to
make it work
so I'm Emily George and I know most of
your books have been in the healthcare
field and I was just wondering if you
had ideas outside of healthcare if you
had all the time in the world what you
would write about well first of all
she's not a plant but she works at area
add Neela has a coach working so she's
part of a team of just two people who
are coaching 520 ambulatory surgery
centers around the country to adopt
effectively the safe surgery work we've
done in outpatient surgery clinics that
don't have all the advantages of
hospitals and so really interesting
great work they're doing what would I
write about if it was outside of
medicine you know I don't really know I
to me I get this little window on the
world and I can use medicine to
illuminate almost anything because you
see human beings coming in and it's
everything from how do we what kind of
career do you have to what is suffering
and what do people go through or how
does the brain work you know I feel like
there's very little the world I can't
capture politics global globalism you
know various kinds of phenomena so I
love that it gives me the full range and
I'd feel really an expert in most other
fields but I'm my one place I grew up a
tennis player playing competitive tennis
and and I don't do it so much anymore
but I feel like it's a world that I have
a little window into and I could imagine
trying something around something like
that
or maybe around writing but there's so
many people who fill pages with writing
about sports and writing about writing
that I feel like I get this unique
vantage point through the eyes of both
trying to practice surgery try to do
Public Health trying to lead a smaller
organization that that I've a list this
long and I'm never going to get through
it in my lifetime so I probably won't be
writing my tennis piece
yes hi I'm Mel I'm an mph student um I
was wondering obviously you left a kind
of burgeoning career in politics at a
fairly early stage in terms of personal
impact using your career and I
appreciate this might be quite hard to
give an accurate off but you feel that
you've had more impact in public health
or you may have had or being able to
have more impact in politics if you'd
carried on and develop that career well
I think it's partly it's trying to be a
little bit honest with yourself about
what you're good at and also what you
have tolerance for so I love trying out
ideas that are kind of a little bit on
the edge and I'm impatient often as my
team will tell me with trying to bring
everybody along and and so entering
politics is all around being able to try
to persuade really a very broad swath of
people to come along I love working with
the early adopters who want to drive
something forward and then use a poll I
come with me come with me
what's let's let's do this and I also
was very impatient with the with the
irrationality of politics the ways in
which you are trying to get lots of
people who fundamentally disagreed on
values or were really arguing about
something else and it was just power and
being effective in dealing with people
whose primary aim is power I was not
that great at it
and and I didn't love it so Bill Clinton
working for him you could see he loved
an enemy he loved the battle he loved
somebody who was really going after him
and he could it energized him and where
it depressed me
and maybe I'll change over time as I get
more confidence in being able to take
that on but dealing with a world that is
going to attack you from every pause you
know I had little glimpses of it so for
example when I wrote an article about
McAllen Texas being the most expensive
the most expensive counties for
healthcare in America you know some of
the attacks that came were around you
know insinuating that I'm a Muslim who
is raising heads connections to
terrorists and was really trying to
trying to harm people in this county in
Texas and it was floated you know first
of all then how do you respond like well
it's not bad if I'm a Muslim I don't
happen to be but how so how do you even
answer that and then you're getting
caught in that whole thing and then
you're just buying into the whole line
of argument it was you know the kind of
stuff I hate rather than fired up like
okay we got a battle we're on so I think
I was I've been about as effective as I
could be considering my personality and
what I hope is that over time I learned
to be effective you know when I first
worked in government I ended up really
resigning and stepping down out of
frustration with the power politics and
just you know if we just did it
rationally we'd be all okay to you know
finding some of that when working with
the whu-oh and just being able to relax
enough to let the politics happen let
the ups and downs and get some patience
with it not enough that I could enjoy
some of the power plays that can go on
but maybe in another 10 years I'll get
better at that and so I feel like that's
a real area that I'd like to learn how
to deal with more effectively the tool
sadly our time is coming to an end so we
asked you in the last couple minutes if
you could sum up what you what you would
like to have the audience take away from
this and particularly in terms of
leadership
well one thing I would say which we
didn't talk much about but struck me
when another friend of ours in patient
safety Bob Walker and I had a
conversation about this and and what he
pointed out was that it's very different
trying to figure out how you lead when
you're under 40 and then how you lead
when you're over 40 and his basic rule
and I like this rule because I think I
followed it intuitively was say yes to
everything when you're under 40 and then
start saying no to pretty much
everything after you're 40 but that you
get this tremendous experience from just
trying things out and saying yes to
almost everything you never quite get
the priorities right and you don't get
the balance right and all of those kinds
of things you burn the candle it all
ends but that was what gave me
tremendous on I just said yes to
everything and I ended up working a
little rock and I ended up writing for
The New Yorker and doing all these kinds
of things and now I'm trying to figure
out how do you you know be sane and
balance it and and achieve the things
that you can achieve and that comes from
a different kind of leadership which I'm
trying to learn how to express at this
later stage somehow I think you'll
figure it out thank you so much